Let's try some slightly more
complicated equations.
Let's say we have 3 times
x plus 5-- I want to make
sure I get all the colors
nice-- is equal to 17.
So what's different about this
than what we saw in the last
video is, all of a sudden,
now we have this plus 5.
If it was just 3x is equal to
17, you could divide both
sides by 3, and you'd
get your answer.
But now this 5 seems to mess
things up a little bit.
Now, before we even solve
it, let's think about
what it's saying.
Let's solve it kind of in a
tangible way, then we'll solve
it using operations that
hopefully will make
sense after that.
So 3 times x literally means--
so let me write it over here.
So we have 3 times x.
So we literally have an
x plus an x plus an x.
That right there is a 3x.
And then that's plus 5, and
I'm actually going to write
it out as five objects.
So plus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
This right here, this 3x
plus 5, is equal to 17.
So let me write the equal sign.
Now, let me draw
17 objects here.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
Now, these two things are
equal, so anything you do
to this side, you have
to do to that side.
If we were to get rid of one
object here, you'd want to get
rid of one object there in
order for the equality
to still be true.
Now, what can we do to both
sides of this equation so we
can get it in the form that
we're used to, where we
only have a 3x on the
left-hand side, where
we don't have this 5?
Well, ideally, we would
just get rid of these
five objects here.
You would literally get rid
of these five objects:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
But, like I said, if the
original thing was equal to the
original thing on the right, if
we get rid of five objects from
the left-hand side, we have
to get rid of five objects
from the right-hand side.
So we have to do it here,
too: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Now, what is a symbolic way
of representing taking
away five things?
Well, you're subtracting 5 from
both sides of this equation.
So that's what we're doing here
when we took away 5 from the
left and from the right.
So we're subtracting
5 from the left.
That's what we did here.
And we're also subtracting
5 from the right.
Do that right over there.
Now, what does the left-hand
side of the equation
now become?
The left-hand side,
you have 5 minus 5.
These cancel out.
You're just left with the 3x.
It's a different
shade of green.
You are just left with the 3x.
The 5 and the negative
5 canceled out.
And you see that here.
When you got rid of these
five objects, we were
just left with the 3x's.
This right here is the 3x.
And the whole reason why we
subtracted 5 is because we
wanted this 5 to go away.
Now, what does the right-hand
side of the equation look like?
So it's 3x is going to be-- let
me write the equality sign
right under it-- is equal to--
or you could either just
do it mathematically.
Say, OK, 17 minus 5.
17 minus 5 is 12.
Or you could just
count over here.
I had 17 things.
I took away 5.
I have 12 left: 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
That's what's subtraction is.
It's just taking
away five things.
So now we have it in a pretty
straightforward form.
3x is equal to 12.
All we have to do is
divide both sides of
this equation by 3.
So we're just left with an
x on the left-hand side.
So we divide by-- let me pick
a nicer color than that.
Let me do this pink color.
So you divide the
left-hand side by 3, the
right-hand side by 3.
And remember what
that's equivalent to.
The left-hand side, none of
this stuff exists anymore,
so we should ignore it.
None of this stuff
exists anymore.
In fact, let me clear it
out, just so that we don't
even have to look at it.
We subtracted it, so
let me clear it.
Let me clear it over here.
And so now we are dividing
both sides by 3.
Divide the left-hand side by 3.
It's 1, 2, 3.
So three groups, each of
them have an x in it.
If you divide this right-hand
side by 3, you have 1, 2 and 3.
So it's three groups of four.
So when you do it
mathematically here,
the 3's cancel out.
3 times something divided by
3 is just the something.
So you're left with x is
equal to, and then 12
divided by 3 is 4.
You get x is equal to 4,
and you get that exact
same thing over here.
When you divided 3x into
groups of three, each of
the groups had an x in it.
When you divided 12 into groups
of three, each of the groups
have a 4 in it, so x
must be equal to 4.
x is equal to 4.
Let's do another one, and this
time I won't draw it all out
like this, but hopefully,
you'll see that the same type
of processes are involved.
Let's say I have-- let me
scroll down a little bit.
Let's say I have 7x.
So 7x-- and I'll do a slightly
more complicated one this time.
7x minus 2 is equal to-- I'll
make the numbers not work
out nice and clean-- is
equal to negative 10.
Now, this all of a sudden
becomes a lot more-- you know,
we have a negative sign.
We have a negative over
here, but we're going to
do the exact same thing.
The first thing we want to do
if we want to get the left-hand
side simplified to just 7x
is we want to get rid
of this negative 2.
And what can we add or subtract
to both sides of the equation
to get rid of this negative 2?
Well, if we add 2 to the
left-hand side, these two
guys will cancel out.
But remember, this
is equal to that.
If we want the equality to
still hold, if we add 2 to the
left-hand side, we also have to
do it to the right-hand side.
So what is the new left-hand
side going to be equal to?
So we have 7x, negative
2 plus 2 is just 0.
I could write plus 0, or I
could just write nothing there,
and I'll just write nothing.
So we get 7x is equal to-- now,
what's negative 10 plus 2?
And this is a little bit
of review of adding and
subtracting negative numbers.
Remember.
I'll draw the number
line here for you.
If I draw the number line--
so this is 9, this is 1.
We could keep going in
the positive direction.
Negative 10 is out here.
Negative 10, negative 9,
negative 8, negative 7.
There's a bunch
of numbers here.
You know, dot, dot, dot.
I don't have space to draw them
all, but we're starting at
negative 10, and we're adding 2
to it, so we're moving in the
positive direction on
the number lines.
So we're going 1, 2.
So it's negative 8.
Don't get confused.
Don't say, OK, 10 plus 2
is 12, so negative 10
plus 2 is negative 12.
No!
Negative 10 minus 2 would be
negative 12 because you'd
be going more negative.
Here, we have a negative
number, but we're
going to the right.
We're going in the positive
direction, so this
is negative 8.
So we have 7x is
equal to negative 8.
So now you might be saying,
well, how do I do this
type of a problem?
You know, I have a
negative number here.
You do it the exact same way.
If we want to just have an x on
the left-hand side, we have to
divide the left-hand side by 7,
so that the 7x divided by 7,
just the 7's cancel out,
you're left with x.
So let's do that.
If you divide by 7, those
cancel out, but you can't just
do it to the left-hand side.
Anything you do to the left,
you have to do to the right
in order for the equality
to still hold true.
So let's divide the
right by 7 as well.
And we are left with
just an x is equal to
negative 8 divided by 7.
We could work it out.
It'll be some type of a
decimal, if you were to use a
calculator, or you could just
leave it in fraction form.
Negative 8 divided by
7 is negative 8/7.
Negative 8/7, or if you want to
write it as a mixed number, x
is equal to 7 goes into 8 one
time and has a remainder of 1,
so it's negative 1 and 1/7.
Either one would be acceptable.